after the first two seasons of the hair
series cream received relatively decent
feedback from the fans
now the third seasons cream is released
three years after the second season the
last news about the series based on Wes
Craven's movies was 2016 with the
Halloween special in feature length
however after a long wait fans of the
masked murderer will not be quite so
satisfied because as it is now clear the
content of the third season produced by
Queen Latifah has hardly anything to do
with his predecessors whether the fans
will get satisfied with him old school
slasher horror remains to be seen but at
least Roger Jackson the killer of the
original movies will return this time
the story takes place in Atlanta and
revolves around the young aspiring
football player who is struggling with
his past in the USA the six episodes of
the third season are to be broadcast on
vh1 next month after we reported about a
new version of Avengers and game last
week we now know what the exact content
of the about seven minute additional
material will be at the latest with the
broadcast of this news episode only the
extended version will be shown in all
cinemas for all of you who are wondering
whether a new cinema visit is worthwhile
or not we will list the new features of
the extended version below the 7 minutes
will consist of a 20-second long
foreword by directors Joe and Anthony
Russo in addition there will be a
post-credits scene with Professor Howie
and the long-awaited tribute to Marvel
creator Stan Lee finally there is a
preview of spider-man far from home
which marks the end of the infinity saga
so whether or not it's worth going back
to the movies is up to each of you to
decide for yourself a few weeks ago we
reported about the potential forthe
matrix part now the ambitions seemed to
become more and more concrete because
after Jon week 3 director and matrix
stunt double Jets the Husky recently
confirmed the involvement of the
Wachowski siblings a shooting star seems
to have leaked out according to
information from geeks worldwide this is
expected to be in the first half of 2020
however the story will not be planned as
a sequel but will simply be set on the
same universe as its predecessors that's
why the main character is not Keanu
Reeves anymore but black panther actor
Michael B Jordan the
script will be written by Zack Penn who
also contributed to the Incredible Hulk
and Marvel's The Avengers
according to geeks worldwide lana
wachowski will take a seat in the
director's chair while other sources
report that lili wallowski will also be
the director in view of the current
rumors it is difficult to predict a
cinema release though it is considered
certain that it will not be before 2021
since the beginning of the week there
have been rumors about the new black
widow film starting one of the
speculations were new pictures from the
set Scarlett Johansson stunt-double
Florence Clark was shown on the set with
a dummy that seems to be based on her in
addition there is a league picture
showing two boxes with the names Natasha
and Jelena some fans combine this with
the fact that Florence black will be
seen as a spy Jelena Bulova alongside
Scarlett Johansson as Natasha Romanov
like Romanov Bulova is also an agent
from the Red Room Academy and also
codenamed Black Widow in the comics she
appears from time to time sometimes on
the set of Romanov sometimes on the
opposite side like Widow is produced by
Kate Shortland and will be shot in the
cinemas at the beginning of next year
the extremely successful science fiction
novel good morning midnight will now be
turned into a film in the new Netflix
project in cooperation with the
Hollywood superstar no one less than
George Clooney will direct the new
project and at the same time slip into
one of the leading roles according to
the Deadland magazine marquel Smith's
script has already been written and the
production company smoke house owned by
Clooney is now waiting for production
start in October the content of Lilly
Brooks Dalton's novel is the story of
two scientists and their fates Augustine
played by Clooney is in search of the
question of infinity after an incident
at his research station at the North
Pole happens he evacuates everyone and
decides to be the only one left behind
shortly afterwards he meets the
mysterious girl iris with whom he has to
deal from now on in one place isolated
from the outside world on the other hand
the fate of the astronaut Sullivan is
tamatha sized who explored the planet
Jupiter with her team and is now
supposed to return to Earth however they
lose contact with earth and now seem to
be lost in the vastness of space all
those who were interested in this
exciting topic will have to wait at
least until autumn next year till the
cinema start
the third part of the Annabelle series
about the terrifying horror dog will
shortly be released in the cinemas the
reviews so far are positive throughout
and even the edge rating which has been
known for a short time should come as no
surprise as it will be r-rated in
contrast to its predecessors the third
part will be based after the story of
conjuring in other words after 1971 the
couple ed and Lorraine Warren finally
want to make the puppet non destructive
in the third part instead of giving in
however Annabelle has a different plan
she wakes up all the other artifacts in
the cellar of the Warrens and puts not
only the Warren parents but also her
daughter in danger Annabelle three will
be in the UK cinemas on 10th of July
2019 the blonde broad saber Flash Gordon
whose film rights Disney has secured
through the Fox Steel will get a new
addition though a three director Taika
Waititi was hired for this however the
plan is not to make a real film like in
the 80s but an animated film John Davis
who already has experience in the
science-fiction business with films like
predator and Waterworld
will take over the production yt to
himself mansions Flash Gordon as an
important influence for his MCU film
tour Ragnarok when Flash Gordon will
save the earth from the intergalactic
Emperor Ming is not yet known
[Music]